before we proceed to tonight's main
event I want to speak a little bit about
the visiting writers program its origins
and what our intention is with this
program began a number of years ago
before I came to Hillsdale it's a long
long long time ago over 25 years and my
former colleague and friend Dan son Dahl
whom some of you may remember was the
director of the program and put it on a
solid foundation he brought some great
writers to campus and his goal in
establishing the program was to try to
replicate here at Hillsdale something of
what he experienced when he was an
undergraduate at Gustavus Adolphus
College in Minnesota where visiting
writers would come now and again and the
people who directed that program did
everything they could to make sure the
writers spent their time with students
now you're at Hillsdale and you may not
realize it but at some place is what
happens is that the writers come to
campus and spend a good deal of their
time in parties with faculty members and
administrators and they will see the
students at a reading maybe at a
workshop and that may be about it and
that's the last thing that I want to
have happen here so every chance we get
we we try to facilitate opportunities
for you I'm speaking to the students to
meet and get to know the writers that we
bring dan as I said put the program on a
superb foundation he made it so easy for
me when I stepped in almost 25 years ago
to run this program in the years
since I came among the writers that
we've brought names that you should know
if you don't know them already include
the poets mark Jarman from Vanderbilt
University
Paul Mariani who was here just a couple
of years ago I think Paul has been here
five times over the years now at Boston
College in his final semester teaching
Andrew Hutchins at Ohio State also in
his final semester teaching be h
fairchild whom some of you may remember
was here not that long ago and among
other writers Ron Hansen from Santa
Clara University Jim Sheppard from
Williams College Toni early from
Vanderbilt John Jeremiah Sullivan from
Wilmington North Carolina and a former
student of our guest this week one of
the things that has been true of all of
these visitors is how generous they have
been with their time with our students I
was just talking to mark the other night
over dinner and just a regular old
conversation and I said I've been
reading a book of short stories a
collection of stories by Joy Williams
and then whose work I had not read
before she's fantastic
and Mark said oh I used to stay with her
and her husband when I would visit New
York oh that's that's impressive to me
am
and later we were I think I was
mentioning Eudora Welty one of my heroes
great great writer from Mississippi had
the misfortune of being from the state
that also produced Faulkner but a
powerhouse in her own right and Mark
said oh I I once interviewed her for the
BBC at her home in Jackson Mississippi
that a great story about how she would
end an interview by appearing to
levitate as I'm sure she could do
because she could do so much and I and
then he was talking to me about how John
Sullivan who I think is just brilliant
beyond brilliant fantastic stylist and
if you haven't read his work you should
buy pop head collection of essays or
blood horses his memoir and history of
thoroughbred horse racing I'll have him
back one of these days well he was Mark
was teaching at the University of the
South Suwannee and Mark had been told
you no uncertain terms you'll get 12
students in this writing class all
seniors you can't admit anyone else and
just a little bit later a young student
that Mark didn't know came in to talk
with him and they spoke for maybe an
hour at the end of the conversation mark
went to find the person who had said no
more and said I'll add one more student
it was John Jeremiah Sullivan who was
either a freshman or a sophomore turned
out to be the best writer in the class
well that's who's with us we'll hear
more about him in a moment but the
generosity of people like Mark Rashard
and John Sullivan and Tony early others
is is something I want all of you in the
coming years as long as you're at
Hillsdale to take advantage of
and so next spring we'll have somebody
back again and so forth as long as we
have this program in place it's a great
joy for me to do this work and a great
pleasure to get to know people like Mark
Rashard and to consider him a friend
though I've only seen him for a total of
three days in my life and it's it's just
wonderful to have him back well to
introduce him more formally tonight I've
asked a senior English and art major a
very fine writer in his own right from
Atlanta Georgia Forrester McClatchy
mark rashard born in Lake Charles
Louisiana is the author of two
award-winning short story collections
the ice at the bottom of the world and
charity as well as a best-selling novel
fish boy his short stories appeared in
The New Yorker Harper's Esquire GQ the
Paris Review and many others his most
recent book the memoir House of Prayer
number 2 was published in 2011 he's the
recipient of the pen Ernest Hemingway
award a National Endowment for the Arts
fellowship awaiting a foundational
writers award a New York foundation for
the Arts fellowship a Mary Francis
Hobson the medal for the Arts and
Letters and a National Magazine Award
for fiction mr. Rashard also wrote the
screenplay stoploss produced by
Paramount and has been a writer and
producer for CBS's criminal mind suspect
behavior
showtimes Emmy Award Emmy Award winning
series huff Chicago Hope on CBS and
party of five on Fox he's also written
and produced for Hell on Wheels on AMC I
hope that those who've read marked for
shards fiction have enjoyed the rewards
of paying close attention to the
porosity the melodies of his prose his
attendance to unique dialects his deep
knowledge of place and a stylistic
bravery make the experience of reading
his work harrowing and lovely whether
tragic comic or limiting the space in
between his stories order the world a
little with each rereading please help
me welcome mark Rashard
they good thank you for uh sir
and thank you John it's it's such a
pleasure to be back here and I feel the
same way about you we have some rules in
our family and I think the old name was
summer bill and summer Vale we may be
distant cousins I would I would only
hope so I feel like I was a name draw
for when it's going everyone he
mentioned go I know that I must say at
their house I trained their dog but in
the case of your door well T it was very
strange because we had to go through all
these master nations to get an interview
with her Jackson and the man who
arranged it was a head of Southern
Studies at Ole Miss and he said don't
stay long and when you when the
interview is over
you will know it I said we'll give me a
hint he said you will know it so I was
there with the producer and we had a
sound guy and you know and I was
starstruck I mean I've worked with
actors and I won't drop their names
because I'm starting to feel
self-conscious but Eudora Welty man
that's Eudora Welty I'm talking to and I
got a little flummoxed and I asked her a
question and then at a certain point she
began to levitate and she just started
to like float and out of he had this big
armchair and it was one of those chairs
that if you sit in you push a button and
it pushes you up into a standing
position but from where we were sitting
she was just starting to float up above
us that I was going interview must be
over now and it was over it's a great
thing you do bringing people here I love
so many of those people especially John
Sullivan who was a trip it was an honor
I don't know how much I taught him he
was a great student though he's going on
to do great work Denis Covington and
what I think is unique about those
people and we were speaking about this
John Sullivan said I'm a leftist and an
atheist
kind of still calm and I think Dennis
Covington is a person whose most recent
book is revelation and search of
religion and violent societies I doubt
that John Sullivan is an atheist I can't
I can't read his work and believe that
so but it does point to a question that
we spoke to with some of the students
today and more recently when I came
before this is a great place and a great
college to find out what your belief
system is and whether you have one or
not let me just say this as a writer
it's good to know a little bit what your
belief system is I mean Flannery
O'Connor certainly knew what her belief
system was and she was able to create
great art I think as a as a young person
you have an opportunity in this place of
higher learning to figure it out to ask
yourself what is my belief system you
may not have any answers and that's fine
that's what it's that's what it's about
but great art is also informed by people
who know what they think and know what
they believe so I'll just suggest that
when he was mentioning these writers
that he did because they're people who
are searching there are people who are
questioning what they think I just I
really don't believe John's an atheist
so he read his work I'm going to read a
story that I've never read in public
it's a little bit chancy because it's a
it's I'm only going to read one story
and my ring or is that just my deafness
I'm okay am i ringing okay that's
television talk I guess it's like you
know as long as the camera is I mean
it's good I'm in focus look I get the
thumbs up but I'd like to read the story
because I'm fond of it and I've had some
I've been thinking about this story for
reasons that have nothing to do with
being here tonight there's a cadence to
it when someone was asking me today
about how you write in first verse the
third person the story often determines
how
you tell the story and there was a
language that this story expressed
itself in that I didn't understand at
first so I may stumble through it a
little bit at times because I don't
understand how the narrator exactly
speaks over why he speaks this way but I
have an idea
and I'd like to make just a couple of
quick remarks afterwards about how this
story came to be because I think that
was instructive to the students today we
did a couple of stories and I said okay
here's how I wrote the story I was due
the next day for a workshop here's how
hold myself through with the craft of it
we've all been in that place where it's
midnight and we had nothing nothing so
this was a story that I'll talk about
afterwards it came to me because I was
in a really boring sermon in the
Lutheran Church because I had believe it
or not had a supermodel girlfriend at
one time I know it's really hard to
believe but when we miss visited her
parents along Highland we were had to go
to this Lutheran Church and the sermons
were really dry to us sort of just kind
of like looking at the Bible you know
while the sermon was going on and so
I'll get into it afterwards but this is
a this is a story called happiness of
the garden-variety I felt really bad
about what we ended up having to do to
fix horse buster today not that looking
back all this could have been helped all
this starting when Steve Willis and I
were ripping the old roof off of where
we live and the shanty by the canal on
Vic's acres Vic was up to Norfolk again
checking on a washing machine for his
many childhood wife Steve Wallace and I
left to Ruth to rip off the roof and to
hammer in new shingles we were doing
this in change for rent every month we
do something and change for rent from
Vic last month previous we strung three
miles of pound net with bottom weights
and cork Stoppers what we changed for
rent usually comes to a lot more
but I'm sure the rent is for our for
room front porch shanty on the canal out
back of Vic's house but Steve Willis and
I like Vic and Vic lets us use his boat
and truck for side business we do on new
moon lights let me tell you something
about what makes what we ended up doing
two Vic's horse buster all the worse
this is not to say about Vic less than
buster me personally and I know Steve
Willis did too hated Buster Steve Willis
having had to watch from far away Buster
killed two of Vic's dogs there'd be a
stomp and a kick of dust and then a
splash in the canal where it's a crab
feast an old [ __ ] or big spot then
there was Buster's biting and kicking of
us humans Buster having bit me on the
shoulder once coming up from behind
while I was scraping barnacles from one
of the Vics gifts and changed for rent
and then he didn't even move when I came
at him with a sharp side at home Steve
Willis had Buster kick in the driver's
side of his car door after Buster had
been in some some weeds they could
sprayed with the wrong powder Buster
kicked in the door so hard Steve Willis
still has to crawl in from the other way
it was this eating that finally got
Buster in the end there not being able
to read the right powder label is
something about Vic which made him have
us around this is what I mean this about
Vic and about what we did to his horse
to make things all the worse Vic could
not read nor write and this about Vic
affected the way we all were with him
what I mean all means Vic's wife and his
children and Buster and his dogs and all
the acres we all lived on down by the
canal and everything on all those acres
and everything on all those acres
painted aquamarine blue because one
thing about Vic and I say this to show
how Steve Wallace and I made this all
the worse was that Vic not reading or
writing see
to make him not to think about things
like they had names that he had to
remember by way of thinking that they
needed spelling but instead Vic seemed
to think about things in groups like
here is a group of things that are my
humans here is a group of things that
are my animals here is a group of things
that I got for free here's a group of
things that I got off of good deal
making and here's a group of things that
I should keep a long time because I got
them from from people who had kept them
a long time and maybe because of a
couple of these reasons put together Vic
had another group of things painted
aquamarine blue because he had gotten a
good deal on two 55-gallon barrels of
aquamarine paint and everything even
Vic's humans and animals who could not
help but rub up against it or sit in it
somewhere because it was everywhere wet
everything was touched the color of
aquamarine though all of us calling it a
Corrine because even spelling it out and
sounding it out to Vic it still came out
of his mouth that way a Corrine keeping
in mind here's a man who can't read nor
write and Steve Wallace and I always
saying it a Corrine like Vic said it for
fun because it also always seemed like
somehow we were always holding a brush
of it somewhere putting it on something
and changed for rent so what made what
we did to buster worse were some ways
and fix thinking which were brought on
by him not reading or writing and just
because somebody had kept Buster a long
time - Vic made it seem Buster was very
valuable and even though the horse did
come with some history tied to it
the real reason the people had Buster
for so long because they were old and
they could not seem to kill the horse by
just shooting it with birdshot over and
over again even though they tried again
and again them just making Buster meaner
and easier for victim I when the two old
people saw him in church and asked
did he want a good deal on a historical
horse the history that Buster had was he
was the last of the horses they used at
Wicomico light station to run rescue
boats into the surf to Steve Willis and
I when we heard it we said so what but
to Vic this was some history he could
understand and appreciate being an old
sailor himself in it being some facts
that he did not have to be gotten from a
history book that he could neither read
from in the first place what I came to
find out later on was the heart tug Vic
felt about this old horse that had to do
with when Vic grew up Vic's father
having boarded a team of surf horses in
a part of the house where Vic slept in
when he was a boy because all the
children from Vic's parents spilled out
of the to room collaborate in the dunes
not a far situation from Vic's own
children who as long as Steve Willis and
I have lived here I don't think I've
seen all of yet because he keeps
spelling out of the house barefoot all
year around and maybe it's because
there's so many of them that Vic can't
seem to remember all their names right
rather than the fact that he can't place
in his mind what they are called because
he can neither read nor write anyway the
point I'm leading to about the Hart tug
is that where Vic spent his life as a
child was sleeping with two other
brothers and a hayloft over a team of
all surf horses and the hayloft mostly
empty at that not even because there was
no hay to be had on an island of sand
but because the team always grazed on
the wild sea oats and the dunes and this
is what makes what we did the worse this
tug on Victor's heart to his younger
days at Buster had me hearing Vic tell
it all to Buster one day when Vic didn't
know I did the feeling Vic remembered
best of laying snug with his brothers
all of them laid over each other to keep
warm during the winter Northeastern's
the two-room clobbered and attacked on
horse stalls where they slept
remembering them in the early mornings
keeping warm
wishing for breakfast while down below
the horses would be stirring to go out
making droppings and the smell coming up
to the warm all over each other brothers
the warm smell of wild sea oats passed
through the two solid horses bringing
sea fog breath so that was the heart tug
Buster had and I don't mean to make Vic
out strange owing to him liking the
smell of an old horse passing gas I
think if you think about it there's
really nothing here that doesn't fit
with a man not thinking thoughts he has
to read nor write but fits well with a
man who thinks of things as being good
when they are human or animal especially
if they came about by getting them for
free or from a good deal I guess that is
the main reason about Vic besides using
his boat and truck on new moon nights at
Steve Wallace and I stuck around us and
a couple of groups and fixed mind mainly
getting a good deal off of a stringing
nets ripping roofs painting everything
not breathing what we called a Corrine
and that is also the main reason what we
ended up doing up all the worse so like
I said this started when Steve Willis
and I were ripping the old roof off of
our four room front porch shanty by the
canal and changed for rent they could
gone to Norfolk because he had heard of
a good deal some people from church had
told him to do with washing machines and
Vic having stood in water barefoot while
plugging his old washer in and getting
thrown against the wall by the electric
shock naturally to his mind thought it
was broken and in needed of replacing
Vic and left in the more in the morning
coming in to get Steve Wallace and I up
around dawn to finish the roof and said
only one simple thing the really easy
thing to please keep Buster out of the
garden no matter what we did then Vic
was off through the gate and his good
deal truck
painted a Kareem blue one light after
supper the week before it was July hot
and before we started Steve Willis and I
just walked around our shanty roof just
looking because the island we live on is
flat with just scrub pine and wandering
dunes and from the single-story up you
can see Wicomico Wright station the
inlet bridge and the big dunes where the
ocean breaks beyond it was a good
morning knowing Vic's wife would come
soon out bringing us some sticks of
fried fish wrapped in brown paper her
knowing for breakfast we usually had a
cigarette and a dr. pepper for a long
time Steve Wallace and I had not made
any new moon runs to stumpy point to
make us watch the one-lane down to Vicks
acres for cars we wouldn't like to looks
off and I could look at Steve Willis as
Steve Willis could look at me and we
could feel good to be one of Vic's
humans in a house on all of Vic's acres
about midway through the morning after
their chores about a half a dozen of
Vic's kids came spilling barefoot out of
Vicks a Corrine Blue House to ride the a
Corrine bicycles and tricycles and to
play on the good deal a Corrine swing
set in Jungle Jim
the older Vicks kids got to play fishing
boat and battleship down on the canal
dock as long as one of them stayed
lookout to keep a count of heads and to
watch for snakes from over my shoulder I
was watching what Buster was up to he
stood looking up at me in the middle of
the midday morning hot yard not seeking
shade like even a common ass would but
just standing there in the yard near
where the incline made of good deal
railway ties came up out of the canal
and led up to the Boatshed Buster just
stood there
not even slapping his tail at the black
flies that were starting to work on
Steve Wallace and I up on the roof
ripping shingles but standing so still
as if knowing not to attract one bit of
attention to himself on his way to he
and
knew where I would rip a roll of
shingles and look over my shoulder and
Buster would be standing perfectly still
still not even slapping his tail with
the black thought flies are even showing
signs of breath in and out of his big
almost to the ground sloshing belly just
standing as they see it was a big kids
toy some big kid was moving around in
the yard when I wasn't looking all the
time moving closer by two or three feet
at a time to the garden so I would rip a
row and look Ripper row and look never
seeing him move even by an inch and I
saw Steve Willis was not even bothered
by looking to keep an eye on Buster out
of the garden
even though Vick had told us both to do
it and the reason was simple for Steve
Willis not to care and it boiled down
and this is it the evening Vic went over
to make a good deal off the old people
who had Buster for so long he wrote
Buster home and when he showed up at the
gate needing one of us Mayor Steve
Willis to come down off the porch of our
shanty to open the gate it was me who
came down to let Vic and Buster in the
yard that's the reason for Steve Willis
not carrying about Buster not one more
thing Steve Willis stayed on the porch
with his feet up on the railing watching
Vick ride Buster ba and me closed the
gate and ever since anything Vick tells
us to do or about or with Buster it is
me who has who does it or me who listens
even though Vick is telling us both it
is me and not Steve Willis all for me
getting down to open the gate that one
time that is why today Steve Willis was
just ripping rose and not looking at
Buster sneak and I tell you this forward
thinking and Steve Willis when we make
our new moon runs I like it then but
around the chores and fixed back acres
it can become tiresome and make you job
shy yourself just about lunchtime just
about the time for the little Vicks
children's to come into the house to get
cold pieces of fried fish and kool-aid
for lunch
the big Vic's children down by the dock
all shouted snake and ran about fetching
nets and poles and Powell's this was a
good time for Steve Wilson odd to break
so Steve Willis and I broke for a
cigarette to watch what would all Vic's
kids be telling around the table that
night all supper long Vic's big kids ran
up and backed the dock trying to catch
the snake with their poles and paddles
and the poor snake ran from one side and
the boat slip was his escape cut off by
one of these big kids poling around and
the washtub trailing a minnow saying one
of Vic's big girl kids caught the
tired-out snake on the surface and
dipped him out with a canoe paddle then
one of the big big boys grabbed it up
and snapped it like a bullwhip popping
its neck so it went limp Vic's dogs the
buster hadn't yet kicked into the canal
barked and jumped up on the boys playing
keep-away with a snake until the boys
took it up to the outside sink where we
clean fish to skin it out and drive what
the dogs didn't eat into the Sun as they
all paraded up to the house I came to
notice the yard seemed even emptier than
it should have been with Vic's kids and
dogs all gone up to the big house and
then I realized what piece was missing
when between the wooden stake rows of
pea beams
I saw a patch of sparrows shot ragged
horse hair and a big horse behind
showing out by the tomatoes I shouted a
couple of times and spun a shingle
towards where Buster was at work
munching cabbage and cucumbers but the
shingle just skipped off this big horse
behind and splashed into the canal by
the time I got down from the roof
leaving Steve Willis up there ripping
shingles Steve Willis not being the one
to open that gate the first time Buster
came into BIG's acres Buster had eaten
half the young cabbage heads we had and
I knew better than to come up from
behind a horse that could kick a
full-grown collie 30 yards so I picked
up the canoe paddle the big Vic's girl
had used to fling up the snake on
dock and went through the corn to cut
Buster off at the cabbage but
head-to-head me shouting and making
up-and-down wild slicing actions with
the canoe paddle Buster had no focus on
me instead he was stopped in mid shoe
then the sides of his almost to the
ground slouching belly heaved out than
in and then more out moving so much more
out that patches of horse hair popped
and dropped off and I took a step
backwards halfway fearing for an
explosion I called for Steve Willis to
come down to hurry up but all Steve
Willis said was what did I want I said I
think Buster is sick from whatever Vic
had sprayed on the cabbage probably not
getting anybody to read the label of
what it was to begin with and then
Buster sidestepped like he was drunk
through two rows of steak strong pea
beans and then he pitched forward to
where I was backing up holding the canoe
paddle a little good I was thinking
against an exploding horse and then
Buster I swear before God
Buster erupt belched and then blew out
broken when loudly at the other end at
the exact same time as his knees shook
out from under him and he went down
among the tallest tomatoes in BIG's
garden wiping out the uneaten cabbage
and some cucumbers - by this time Steve
Willis come down off the roof to look at
the tragedy we were having in Vic's
garden it was hard to count the amount
of summer suppers Buster had ruined and
smushed Steve Willis called Buster a
son-of-a-bitch for wiping out the
tomatoes because Steve Willis is
favorite sandwich being tomato with
heavy pepper and extra mayonnaise Steve
Willis asked me did I hit Buster in the
head or what with the canoe paddle but I
promised I hadn't given him a lick at
all though we were both looking at how
hard I was holding on to the handle
Steve Willis pushed in on Buster's big
blowing up belly with his toes
and air started to hiss out of Buster's
mouth like a nail stuck tire and the
fear of explosion having not completely
passed we both gently step back you
could tell the little hiss was coming
out here where Buster's big black and
pink tongue stuck pretty far out of his
mouth laying in the dirt between where
the tomatoes were smushed and the
cabbage used to be steve willis said
this is not good
usually when steve willis and i have a
problem in our on the side new moon
business we say we have to do some big
thinking and we are always seeming to be
doing big thinking in all of our
business but since this was a buster
problem as in steve willis didn't come
down off the porch that first time to
open the gate it was coming clear to me
I would have to be the big thinker on
this one I stepped back to think really
big about this tragedy figuring from
where the garden is situated around the
Boatshed by our shanty on the canal you
can't see it from the big house so I
figured I had a fair while to figure out
where to go with Buster after I got him
out of the garden hoping to find a hole
big enough nearby for such a big animal
and to do it all the while Vic's little
children slept out of the afternoon Sun
and while Vic's big children with the
afternoon Bible study and the first part
of thinking big I went up to the garage
to get the good deal rotting lawn more
to yank Buster out until I remembered it
had a broken clutch and when I came back
Steve Willis was holding back a laugh to
himself and I will say this about Steve
Willis he's not one to laugh right in
your face he was holding back a laugh
holding the Rope I'd given him to put
around Buster to yank him out Steve
Wallace asked me what kind of knot would
I suggest he tie a dead horse to a
broken riding lawnmower with
I can see how far I could get Steve
Willis to help with the Buster tragedy
so I took the line out of his hand and
put a timber hitch around one of
Buster's hind legs singing out loud a
timber hitch seems to work pretty well
thinks the whole hell of a lot I paid
the line out from the garden and started
to get that sinking feeling of jammed
panic a panic closing and needing some
very big thinking and not to judo
hunting these hot Sun in the art baking
waves of heat making me feel any better
at all you get that sinking panic
feeling and I got it so bad that while I
was paying out the line across the yard
and even though I knew I could never
ever possibly do it I stopped and held
hard to the line and I gave it a good
solid pull the hardest I could to yank
Buster out of the garden straining
pulling even when I thought it was
hopeless and even with a panic worsening
I had to let go of the line and all the
difference I had made was it now there
was air hissing out from one of the
black flies were moving around and
settled back beneath Buster's big
stringy tail well this was even better
than before to see Willis who'd step
behind what tall tomatoes were left so
he wouldn't have to laugh at me to my
face I picked up a shingle at flying it
Buster from the road and spun it towards
Steve Willis but it sliced to the right
it shattered our side kitchen window and
Steve had to go behind the Boatshed -
laughs not in my face at this time after
you couldn't hear the glass falling in
the shanty anymore so I gathered up the
line bunched at my feet and trailed it
over to the Boatshed down to the dock
Vic's big Harker Island rig our new moon
boat with the Chrysler inboard was
gassed up with the key rusted in the
ignition I cleated the line that ran
across the yard from Buster's hind leg
onto the stanchion on the stern and
shouted over to Steve Willis in the
garden to at least help me throw off the
lines I felt for an instant better
starting up the big deep throat in in
the floorboards buzz my feet feeling the
feeling I get that starts to set in
running the rig over to the hidden dock
on the South Bay Shore on our new moon
nights the feeling of the chance of
sudden money the possibility of anything
even danger and death and feeling now in
a jewel our hot Sun the feeling of big
thinking away out of this bad tragedy
with the engine running it was now
possible in my mind that we wouldn't
lose our place of life and fix Akers
over something like letting a big horse
die I was feeling better as Steve
Wallace threw off the stern line and I
choked the raps on the stanchion leading
to where I could just see two big legged
hopes hung up on the tomatoes rackets
Nash Buster out and decide what to do
then but the sound of the big engine
turning over brought out the dogs from
underneath the big house them being used
to going out with Vic in the mornings to
check five miles of pound net and then
some of the older kids not yet set off
for bible study started to spill out of
the house to see what Steve Willis and I
were up to this time with their daddy's
boat and if I looked harder at the house
which I did I could see little Vic's
children in the windows with diapers and
old Vic's t-shirts on wanting to follow
the big kids out but not coming them
having to sleep in them in a way from
the afternoons son Vic's dogs got down
to us first even old Izzy's tan and gray
snout us now she lets babies pull
without snapping and us now which would
when you were bent over and fooling with
getting a long hose turned on come up
and give you a friendly goose in your
rear-end even old Lizzy's tan and gray
snouts nald back to show ripped wood
like wolf like teeth when she saw that
old bastard of a horse and Buster was
down and then she and all of the other
dogs were on the carcass and there was
no keeping them away now I had the
problem of everybody in Vicks acres
coming down to see what I had let happen
to Buster topped off by the dogs having
their day going after
there's body biting his hind legs and
ripping away at the ears and the
privates the sight of the dogs on Buster
was no less than the sounds they made
blood wild and here came the rest of the
kids to see all this this even being
better than chasing the watersnake
around and out of the canal for a supper
table story I had two big think quick so
I pulled Steve Willis by his belt into
the boat uh starting over at that point
about me and him and anything to do with
Buster for getting the first time him
not getting down to open the gate
I pushed forward on the throttle but did
it swinging the bow off where I knew the
sandbar was still being in the right
mind to know not to double up a dead
horse tragedy with bad boatsman ship
when I rounded the dock in the line
leading to where the pack of wild acting
animals were in the tomatoes with a
horse carcass snug tight bowel rose and
the stern squared and I gave that big
ole lovey Chrysler of the gas and
looking over my shoulder I saw Buster
slide from the garden was still the dogs
around this time giving chase to the
dragging legs because in their simple
minds they were probably thinking the
only way to stop something with legs as
to bite its feet whether that something
is standing on them or not I knew that I
was not just pulling Buster out of the
garden now but that we had him sort of
in tow so that as we turned on the to
the canal proper and Buster skidded
across the bulkhead and onto the dock
that I knew wouldn't take his weight I
really had to pour the engine on and I
was right Buster's big body humped the
bulkhead over and came down splintering
the dock we had just been tied to but
for an instant even over the dogs
barking and the children yelling the
deep throated throttle of the engine
giving me anything of anything making me
feel better about this just for an
instant I heard Buster's hopes hid and
clutter across the good deal planking of
the dock before bringing it down and in
that second of hearing horses hopes on
plank
and had to turn back quick and look
because it passed over me that maybe I
would see Buster galloping behind us
giving chase to me and Stig Willis I
will fix garden instead of us dragging
his big dead body out to sea in tow we
still had plenty of canal to cover
before we broke out into the open ocean
the dogs raced along the scientists on
the bank of the canal as far as they
could but it was a game to them now
there wolf-like leaps mellowed out into
a tongue flapping Lopes a couple of
neighbors out on the canal down came a
couple of the neighbors on down the
canal came out to watch and the wake and
spray from Buster cutting along
ass-backwards threw water into their
yards one of the cousins Malcolm was
working in a boat and seeing his coming
he held up a pair of water skis pointing
to Buster laughing as we passed but I
could see open ocean so I throttled down
and lean hard forward to balance against
the rising bough I was glad I had enough
forward thinking of my home to pull
Steve Willis into the book starting us
over about Buster because I could look
at him in the stern watching the big
horse carcass we had in tow by stiffed
up leg and looking at Steve Wallace I
could see it was sinking in on him that
when Vic came home from Norfolk and
threw me out of the back acres by the
canal it would be Steve Willis himself
being thrown out - I've burned up about
three hours of fuel looking for the
right place to cut Buster loose one
problem we had was one time we stopped
to idle the engine and pull off the
floorboard so I could check the oil and
while we set to drifting Steve Willis
notice that Buster floated you could
tell how the body was like a barrel just
below the surface that it was the air or
the gas or whatever was in Buster's big
belly keeping him afloat when I got up
from checking the oil through to where
Steve Willis was standing in the stern a
Marlinspike and he looked down at the
spike and then he looked up to me like
he was saying Oh No
not gonna punch a hole and I look back
at him wiping the oil off of my hands
looking back like oh yes you will punch
a hole and when it came time for me to
cut Buster loose out near the number
nine see boy and it came time for Steve
Willis to punch a hole I did and he did
and it was done so here we are really
feeling bad about what finally ended up
doing to Buster's Vicks horse buster us
drinking about it in the first flight
lounge after we called Vic's wife at
home and she said uh-huh nah to the side
waste questions we asked her about Vick
being home yet trying to feel out how
bad was the tragedy and her hanging up
not saying goodbye and us wondering did
she always do that and then us realizing
we'd never talked to her on the
telephone before after we tied up dicks
rig in the ditch behind the first flight
lounge we started to wonder if shouldn't
we have let Buster had his say about
what to do with his finally dead horse
so there in started as having the lack
of forward thinking and a big thinking
and instead we were left to second
guessing and after we had left the rig
with it's better feeling home and came
in to drink with the drink buzzes coming
on ourselves we started to feel naked in
our thinking especially when a neighbor
of Vicks came in and shook his head when
he saw us and then walked back out so
what Steve Willis and I have done is to
get down off the wall the tide chart and
figure out where the most likely place
for Buster to wash in this we'll head
over there when the tide turns and wait
for Buster to come in on the surf and
then drag him up to take him home in a
truck will somehow big think our way to
fetch by morning the tide tonight turns
around 2:30 just about the lout just
about when the lounge closes to so that
is when we think we will make our move
to the beach in front of the Holiday Inn
where it's where we expect Buster back
so Steve Willis and I sit in the first
flight lounge not having the energy to
begin to think about where
are to live after having to get ready to
be kicked out of Vicks acres much less
having the energy too big think about
pulling a sea bloated horse out of the
surf at 2:30 in the morning here we are
sitting not having the energy to big
think about all of this when Vic walks
in barefooted and says gentlemen
gentlemen another one of the waves he
says things because he can't read nor
write and doesn't know how things are
spelled to speak them correct there's a
nervous way people who don't drink say
preachers act in bars but that is not
Vic Vic sits at our table open-armed and
stares at all the faces in the place
square in the eye including our own we
turned down he sits at the table that is
for drinking like it could be a table
for anything else Vic says he saw his
rig tied up in the ditch behind the
lounge on the way home from Norfolk we
want to ride home and come get it in the
morning
steve willis and i settle up and stand
to go out was vic who says he's excited
about the good deal he's come back with
looking at steve willis i see is to me
to start telling thick about us having
to wait for his favorite animal in his
animal group to wash up down the beach
all at our hands out in the back of
Vic's truck vikrant's his hands over the
six coin washing machines something he
does to all his new good deal things to
make them really his own big says he got
them from a business that was closing
down want his wife be happy
big says our next change for a rent will
be to rewire the machines so they can
run without putting in quarters what did
we think I start to tell Vic about
Buster and the tragedy in the garden I
can't see him Vic in the dark when they
turn off the front lights to the first
flight lounge but I can hear him say
uh-huh uh-huh as I talk when I finish
the part with Steve Wallace and I
waiting for the tide to turn Vic says
come on boys we are
to get them home Arden we all three of
us sit up front of the truck riding
across the causeway bridges home all
fixed says for a while is well my horse
old horse not finishing the rest if
there is anything to finish and I get
the feeling Vic is rearranging groups in
his mind like his animal group things
and his human group things and his good
deal off of people things and maybe a
new group of really awful people things
with just me and Steve Willis in it but
then Vic starts talking about how it
changed for rent Steve Willis and I are
also going to build a laundry platform
with the cement foundation and a pine
rafter shedding and Vic starts to talk
like even after taking rearrangement of
all his things and all his groups
everything still comes up okay Vic says
Auton we lay the foundation around the
downside of the shanty where Steve
Willis and I live so the soap water can
drain directly into the canal and after
we figured out how to put the sidings
and braces up often we put a couple of
coats of paint on it to keep the weather
out maybe and change for some rent and
what color what us boys say would look
good and Steve Willis and I both sit
forward and yell a Carine at the same
time us all laughing and me feeling
happy crossing the last causeway bridge
home I'm happy heading there as a human
and Vic's acres again
you know I don't know about this story I
don't know about that story it's a it's
a it's a long story but I will have to
say as an ambitious young writer reading
through the old test and I was always
thinking I would write stories based on
biblical tales so that's my version of
the story of the garden and and Adam and
Eve and I read a story when I was here
last time called gentlemen's agreement
which was about Abraham and Isaac I've
written a couple more yeah that's what
12 year old says at the end of the
sentence yeah it was like it doesn't
know how to proceed after that but thank
you for letting me read that I don't
really read it often and I thought maybe
if you had any questions I know we're
nearing on the nine o'clock hour if
anybody had any questions or any
anything they want to talk about John or
class yes ma'am what I can't hear
well thank you I just I'm so deaf all
right thank you but that was also to the
people I met this afternoon for workshop
remember we were talking about the
congestion and how if you need to learn
how to if you can't need to figure out a
place to go
just repeat where you've been a little
bit to give you a little bit of leverage
and springboard that story it was full
of it even though I kind of and sadly
the story is semi autobiographical and
it was a terrible day it's just like one
of those really bad days but yeah
anybody else yes ma'am how much detailed
to give the characters and describing
them that's a good question um for
example in this story it was less
important to talk about Vic in his
physical description it was more
important to talk about Vic as what he
sees in his world view because that was
the only crucial part Steve Willis we
don't even know what he looks like
we can guess because it's there outdoors
all the time and they're both on the
water just enough it would be my answer
to that and let the reader I mean I
always think that the reader is an
intelligent reader who fills in the
blanks so I'll give them and I'll lead
them on and let them fill in the rest
and let them have the aesthetic pleasure
of helping me color in the canvas you
you really you have to stick to generic
types because when it comes to casting
you don't know what you're going to get
and you may get someone who is just
wildly different than the description
that's in the script so you go you know
Eric 30s handsome what you don't say and
we talked about this so much bad
television is written by white males and
middle-aged white males who are often
lazy in their descriptions and it
translates into laziness throughout the
script and it's fraudulent dishonest
writing sometimes when they go and the
example I used was just a couple of
weeks ago I saw it in a script Cindy
description Cindy hot but doesn't know
it now
let me tell you a white male middle-aged
guy wrote that if Cindy's hot she knows
you know let's just start with that
it's lazy riding and it even goes into
developing the character the other
example we used is okay we got to make
this woman tragic this just happened a
week before last what does a white male
go they go oh she's got a rape in her
history and I'm thinking you know what I
know a lot of women who are tragic that
haven't been raped can we do something
else can we just think harder coming
right harder for these characters so
yeah as they say I lacy writing makes me
crazy just makes me crazy but I don't
get too specific in the detail unless
it's a unless it's a character who is
one of the lead characters and then
sometimes you're surprised you know you
would never have thought this character
this actor for this role and they come
and nail it so you try to be a little
bit loose or open somebody's asking me
over here their hand yes sir what about
it requires first-person um I think it's
almost in the tradition of the southern
story where it's if such when we talked
about this a little bit there are times
when circumstances are so unbelievable
that you have to work yourself up to it
I can't tell Vic that we poisoned your
horse and we drugged him out to sea all
in one breath it's almost like and I
can't tell an audience member of that
but I I work slowly and it's an eye and
I need to pull you by your lapel and
intimate something to go look man this
is where we lived these are the people
we live with this was in their
constellation of things we're not bad
people were not all good people this is
what happened so I think that the first
person was for me a way to get intimate
with the reader for something that was
hard to believe I mean like I say
whether it happened or not
is insignificant but I knew I was going
to write about this one day and I knew I
had to come into it in a very personal
imagine this story told in a very high
speak speech it wouldn't have worked you
know a high third person and the the
young men who you know had a living
smuggling dope and also were you know
and then the horse expired
unfortunately eating the cabbage
contrary to advice a rope using a temper
hitch was secured to the horse's rear
leg
you know just it's not it's not like I'm
not drawing you in I'm just it's just
reportage and the first person allows me
to tell you I feel bad about this man
I'm I was complicit I'm the villain feel
bad about this and I'm hoping but
showing my culpability that you have
some sympathy for my plight even if it's
unearned and I didn't mean to do it this
is like somebody going I didn't mean to
eat the apple I had to do some big
thinking in that Apple and I ate it and
it did this thing and I was gonna get
kicked out of the garden and I lied and
I told the truth but I was accepted and
God had his open arms and all that stuff
the great thing about modeling short
stories on myth or parables is that it
gives you a structure and if it doesn't
work toss it out but when you're I wrote
all these stories in a workshop sorry
and often they were written late at
night when they would do a couple of
days before they were due I was
bartending I'd write him at the bar and
that gives you kind of an immediacy but
they become confessional a lot of these
stories are kind of confessional which
was fun I don't want to keep yes yes sir
yeah another good and we had a question
about that today I'm I'm from all school
where what's not old school it's a
different school where I believe in told
dialogue because I feel like that that's
genuine when I when I read lines of
dialogue in a book I'm feeling a
distance between that you know that
immediate see that I've got covered with
the writer now the writers going and
here's what people said I'm going dude
you were just leading me by my lapel and
you're throwing all this up I don't know
what I'm supposed to think you told me
before someone so said that's an that
I'm thinking that's important dialogue
because you said they said it but when
you're throwing up the dialogue in those
lines I don't know now you gonna make me
think you're supposed to be seducing me
you're supposed to be leading me you're
supposed to be revealing this that's in
fiction in TV you don't get the luxury
of that it is dialogue-driven
and especially because we're watching so
much of on tablets now you're not seeing
as much it's just the dialogue is
pushing the story forward that was a
hard thing for me to learn was how to
get story moving with dialogue and not
be Aaron Sorkin who writes so much and
it's brilliant but not a lot of
television it's like that but you learn
it I think television is crass that you
can learn to me it's really hard I have
a hard time with it my scripts can be
ponderous and it's easier for me to work
on someone else's show where I can just
say oh no they said that and they said
this and do some tricks but it's a whole
different style of writing it's been
good it's been healthy for me as a
writer to learn that type of dollar but
I will not put dialogue and in my work I
just it's just not my style
I don't want to keep you because it's
nine o'clock I'm gonna hang out though
and if y'all want to everybody has a
question I'm happy to hang out and talk
but again thank you all for coming and I
hope you like that story I had a couple
other things I was going to read that
I'd read last time one never read that
so thank you for bearing with me on that
thank you